[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
i'll see you guys
okay
what
do
so
listen to me
plus
things
hey
[Music]
oh
um
oh
thank you
food
yes
[Music]
uh
uh
oh
um
[Music]
sample
she's so much bigger for you
all right
okay
me
and everything
uh
2 30 in the morning
your body
[Music]
oh
[Music]
boys
[Music]
oh
oh
numbers
oh
[Music]
can i see him
come on
you don't know if you wanna
yes
[Music]
ready
oh
oh
i'm
chickens
you guys put it down
uh
[Music]
exactly
you guys
you
oh
so
so
come on
that is
well
okay
so
up
[Laughter]
dc
nobody
okay
yes
hello
say
[Music]
hey
we are just
is
is
is
yesterday and forever so just like you
prayed for children of
israel just like you locked the walls of
your home now
just like david spoke alive with three
[Music]
so believe me just be standing here
listen to me friends
listen to me the bible says you want to
put a thousand to life but you can put
10 000 of life
how many people are out here how many
everybody get one person and send their
most likely one person and tell them
to see people tell them to see your
brothers and sisters
white people we need you to stand up for
us
we need you not just to say it hurts us
[Music]
no
with the blood of jesus and the bible
says when i see the flood
i will pass forward you'll tell the
devil when they come to your step
to pass over me and over my home
over my children in the name of jesus
but the bible says that my people that
are called by my name
will humble themselves and praise seek
my face
turn
[Music]
my foreign oh jesus and i will kill
the land i will convince you and i will
kill the land our land is broken
our land is broken we have coded trying
to kill us and take us out
we have police killing our children it
is
nothing's enough we are drawing the line
in the stand and we say
no more we are calling out to you god
[Music]
rain damn your fire we need you
here we need you at the police
department protecting the people
that are standing up we need you
lord hold up to god we need
you
do not be afraid hell and devil in hell
to go back to hell he has defeated his
loss
and that is why he's trying to take our
people
protect our people give
grace and peace to the family
supply all of their needs and according
to your
pictures
thank you lord
children or cover our children with the
blood
of jesus cover our children as they go
out protect them
we put a hedge of protection around them
in front of them on the side of them and
behind them favor is following them
we are going to put in the specific
[Music]
racism
[Music]
we need you we need your help we need
you
we cannot do this alone bless you bless
you
bless you jesus
is
these police stop killing us and they
steady doing the same
thing to us
it's not a coincidence that it happened
here again
he's been directly hit to our young ones
and i'm here to let the youth know
you're gonna keep riding on
we're not gonna let up everybody going
to the police coming after this
but it's also to know that now we gonna
get justice out of here
these ain't just won't be heartfelt
moments and then under the unrest
the man who got me inside the minnesota
state fair got
killed over north in a car accident
somebody borrowed red sky
here figure out
how to get involved
and so when we talk to legislators when
you see
someone like brooklyn center the mayor
come out we need to begin
to get input from you
and adults alike and drill they have
with straight facts and knowledge about
what this change is going to look like
and understand that god
has the keys for that change i am one
man
i can do my part and my purpose but is i
don't have all the answers
i do know we need to use the mental
health and wellness
brooklyn center lost 20 billion
overnight
we have to keep this right here
every single day at five o'clock
every day until
we just lose number i'm gonna show up
it's been my life
i've already jumped off the deep end
with it years ago
so this is all i know we need y'all to
come with us
it can't be going to work next day come
back get everything to say
but
[Music]
don't make sense don't make sense
that we keep over and over and over
protesting
i've been out here seven years i'm done
marching
you understand we went from philippines
right at the brianna taylor do you have
choice fluid
and now we got dante wait
this angry
for somebody to listen
i don't believe you i don't believe i'm
a man
[Music]
our black folks like that because in
this trench in this mud and is that's
your little army
can you go on now i'm gonna know we can
rejuvenate you
and we're gonna get with this uh
entrepreneurial name
so you can find how to fight for your
man
this all get different
when you out of this and then they try
to silence your voice
and you say you can keep trying because
god got me
and the truth won't reveal itself
you're not gonna keep killing us and
think it's sweet
you can't tell me 20 buildings burning
down overnight and something sustainable
this is not sustainable
this is hurt over and over and over
and when you go to reach up for help too
you're reaching the people that don't
even look like you so within this young
mental health and wellness that we're
advocating
at the stake right now that they can't
run
from everybody else been running from it
i've been out here in the mud
too [ __ ] long for us not to have a
community center
like stephon clark's the birthday party
jumped up on the thing and said we need
a community center
we gave him a playground that's
it
we need a hundred my goal is to build a
hundred of these
mental health wellness centers every
year
you understand we're no small
[Music]
i've been running for my all life and
i'm still going well so when you say
something like dante wright why are you
getting the kind go
like i said you're not going to put me
in that cow
i'm not going i'm not i promise you i'm
not going
ask all the officers
we that way all the way
challenging i'm still alive i know y'all
don't want me
but i'm here and i'm not going nowhere
so really challenging the one-on-one
you see this truck we part of this
country too
i took that from the state give me this
we need this to vote oh yeah any i wish
somebody will roll up on one of
the ministers you go on
we have to protect our children i'm only
doing something i wish my daddy would
kick
and i wanted it
this is cut so deep and we
finally get to air our lungs out and
tell you the truth of
the al shutters in the world going on
and over and over
you got that bad air bi and then next
you know you keep getting not guilty
verdicts or something
that's yeah so i'm here to help all uh
i'm here to help legislators accountable
lawmakers accountable
and
together
i want to give it to my mans right here
frank niddy
people out here all the way from
wisconsin there's people from all around
the world there's somebody sweetie
this is hurting you can't do
nothing to bring this man back
but we know it was actually you cannot
bring this man right
and as a black man you have to
understand he was born
and i got three kids and you want me to
be proud go back to work tomorrow
you brought sick in the morning i
thought i was thinking
they thought i would say hey i like the
way i did
i don't care what straight
i don't take for granted i wake up i
thank god
thank you good lord my cup is half full
i need more
because right now he's down
but now ain't nothing i'll win
if somebody said they pass legislation
good job slap they
tell them no no no no no no no
this family head deserves only to be
dead in front of the president with the
community behind us
tell him turn it over this president
needs to come on down
there's just enough of that and they
need to be in front of community because
i got to play
i'm gonna go ahead and let pray maybe
let them know something but
it's it's real hurtful to have to see
people march
in part because all the way from
wisconsin to washington d.c
to try to protect people like dante
right
and here we are again
[Music]
right yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
part about it is it shouldn't have
happened and it's gonna happen again
every time this happened all these media
run out here
all these different news things all
these celebrity personalities they run
out here
and
they fight for your family because at
the end of the day in a few weeks
y'all are not going to be here and the
worst part is in a few weeks
the numbers go the window down not the
activists
not the activists but the regular people
yeah y'all come out here for a little
bit then you are going away
and then they take it to jail and then
we gotta fight these cases
and then they ban us from being able to
go they've banned people from freeway
right now
from beyond the federal memorial spot
they abandoned activists and guardians
and they don't understand what's going
on they're getting used to this
they've gotten accustomed to the way
that we do things they got accustomed to
the number going in down they're going
to wait us out
they're going to try to wait y'all out
this family needs to audition for
support
they need your team support they need to
make sure that they got your
team support week after week after week
after week y'all got to stay out here
with you
get off from work before y'all go to
work y'all gotta come out here and
support these nurses and support these
families
where y'all never gonna get changed
these people on tv not gonna get tracked
the people that are interviewing not
gonna get you all changed they're not
here i can't get the change i don't live
here
when i'm gone they don't need people
fighting for them
like i fight for them somewhere else
they don't need y'all to come
every day to this stuff i don't care who
throwing it i don't care if y'all don't
like the group doing it i don't care if
y'all don't like each other
we ain't gotta like each other we gotta
put our differences to the side
and fight for this family activist gotta
put make differences to the side
organizations gotta put make differences
to the side everybody gotta put their
differences to the
they don't care police don't care they
put their differences to the side every
day
when they kill jordan floyd the other
three officers didn't do [ __ ]
they sat there and why they that's what
they do they stick together no matter
what
we got to do the same thing we got to
stick together no matter what
they're going to try to give us little
lady justin's little stuff we need two
things
one whatever the family wants whatever
they want y'all make sure y'all find out
what they want
before y'all go talking to the media
about what they need find out what they
want
they got their own justice that they
want they got their own demands they all
need that they want
they need data and then we keep fighting
let's let them sign
out here marching that was just still on
chatting
we won't judge us for all but and if we
get legislative
we can't keep that so y'all got to keep
fighting family y'all got to keep
fighting with each other y'all got to
stick together
y'all gotta make sure that y'all hold
each other's coming to keep up with this
fight
it's an everyday fight they're gonna try
to wait us out and play decide to wait
us out and wait us out
that's how they do things let us fight
each other
at least for the next two months they
should have no problems
[Music]
i don't care if they even know me but i
want them to be taken care of
because they got to be taken care of you
think about knowing each other you're
thinking about cameras
this ain't about organizations getting
credit it's about their family right
here they look
making sure we get justice for this
family to make sure that your family be
taken care of because justin
ain't gonna heal the pain y'all see what
they doing they're terrorizing us
we was out there last night they
arrested 60 people
but then let the white people go i
watched them
go watch the lives they let the white
streamers go say this
warning they already told them to go
home that's what they wanted they told
them to go home
they let them white people call how do
you arrest
anybody when you order after people who
did you think need to be arrested and
who don't
everybody was out there being peaceful
they let the people go
with warm white people unarrested in
this country
well we get arrested in charge and
terrorizing everything
when they go in our community throwing
them flashbacks they don't care about
the little kids in the windows
that's the residential neighborhood
there's a brother that's your
neighborhood they throw into your
gassing
that's a black community ain't throwing
tear gas everywhere flashback
they don't care about the residents at
all they don't care they just show you
they don't care
i didn't mean around the country they
block white neighborhoods off
and don't let you go with it that's what
they do whenever we protest we can't
even marx and they should
they block it off the street everything
up they do not care about
us and they never don't care about us so
we got to sit together
excuse me i'm sorry we got to stick
together we got to keep going
we got to support this family and we got
to make sure we get justice for that
side
all right well with that we're going to
get back to the mc's
whoever that is i'm sorry i don't know
who the mc is what's up
okay
that's what we need to know around this
country is that his life
live that's the kind of person he was
made instead of what they're trying to
make him portray
and only tell people
um
it's a parent thing katie i love
um
is
every year
honestly i'm saying like they don't like
[Music]
wow
um
[Music]
anybody
real
and you can't grab them you take the
town
so like that's that's the thing this is
feeling like this this
is [ __ ] all this stuff like man we
appreciate
everything but like
[Music]
10 years old
let's talk about the facts
[Music]
went
that's what we want to hide
he's ready
it's just one thing i can't understand
why they take it look what may hurt look
at him
and look at him and say oh he needs to
die
oh a taser a cage or a taker
but you know the difference between a
taser and a gun
that's what i'm trying to figure out
took my brother life for nothing
for nothing at all
i'm just trying to figure out why this
lady get a pat on the back
oh she can just go yeah you ain't gonna
do nothing
but you gonna kill take a life from an
innocent man
my brother when he
you've just been in his presence love
looked at my spirit
i love my brother so much and this is
unbelievable
this is unreal it don't feel like he's
still he caught
i feel him here but reality he's gone
and i can't never see him in person
again can never
feel my brother and give him a hug
because they took him from me
they took it from us
[Music]
this is not real i'm done speaking back
i am
this is where the energy belongs
to
in them that they want to get out as
explanation
as what the whole world already need to
see
how you didn't look at the video do you
know how to read already
this is what we need to uplift
if they have a story underneath it
help echo that rewrite it on your
facebook post
rewrite it on the game put mix it down
do something with the truth spoke
it ain't no circle this ain't for
our movement to get in the way
we don't have time for that
we have to center this energy
to this family and give them the respect
and get the story told it's to do to
your voice
to record that
uh
police department and um
again i want to echo what my man said
they know what they want and they add
a story that needs to be done all right
you ain't never gonna catch our movement
in the mix of messing this up
now i demand
[Music]
[Music]
because what he spoke was true
let's talk about this six foot man
oh this young man like this that's wrong
they did they could have done a hundred
different things
and get his family to love and respect
don't jump on that camera
remember um that this hurt it doesn't go
away like you may be able to go home
and forget some people can go to work
tomorrow's business as usual it's not
business as usual for everyone
so remember that in the weeks and the
months to come remember
remember remember father in the name of
jesus we just thank you for
these people every person here every
household representative right now lord
we're just asking that you would touch
everyone here
wrap them in your piece it passes all
protect their families protect their
children protect even their bloodline
lord jesus outside of time
and eternity so we can just be
recovering over our children's
children in the name of jesus can do all
things for the people that are going to
cover them you um cover the people that
are at the police station now
cover them with your glory with your
mercy lord give them just perfect
uh perfect circumstances through
protesting this passage would just
hold back the national guard with the
people that have
just the tactics that they have been
using that they would
they would stop that they would see that
the people are able to protest
which is their constitutional right um
in the name of jesus that we're able to
go there and everybody
at the end of the night it gives all
those sakes to their family
and to their children lord even as we go
to our homes we just ask
your spirit to lead us there we just
have a room
as we pass through the world just touch
us
and fulfill your spirit
we need your peace lord we need your
peace and your covering we need
protection
for all of our people protection for our
children protection
for our boys protection for our girls
lord even
we just bring to you the father lord
there is nothing
a father's legacy lord for the father or
success you would
wrap him in your perfect love that you
would touch him or he has hurt you but
he would touch his heart
you know that it's when things like this
happen we think so much about the mother
but the father
the hurt of the father that hurt that
men men cannot
always express the pain that they have
inside of them because they have to be
strong
so for his straightforward we asked that
you would wrap him
he has quiet moments alone that you
would need him
that you would hold him that you would
rock him and just give him
that you would sue him that you would
give him comfort lord comfort everyone
here
and let us not forget let us not forget
to be each other's people we are each
other's people
we are do you know why in the bible with
where that comes from
my brother's keeper that is because pain
killed abel he killed his brother and
god said where is he and he said what am
i my brother's keeper
we are our brother's keeper we are we
have to
open our eyes we have to look at our
brothers and sisters we have to see them
we have to speak about them we have to
tell other people
look at them look at them look at us
we're screaming look at us the lord in
the name of jesus let this
word not fall on deaf people
let them remember the family as they go
remember pray for them remember the
words of prayer even if they have never
prayed before we're just calling out
believing that we could make a change
something has to change something has to
break so we just thank you
but you are a god that what you did
before jesus
love you
um
[Applause]
right
[Music]
oh
so that would be
yes
all right
okay sweetie
thank you
oh
foreign
oh
my god
good job
[Music]
okay
yes
oh
oh um
thank you
oh yeah
hey is
[Music]
yes
6433
i